the sister of one of the victims and
what's likely the most high profile
murder case of all time is slamming True
Crime shows for not doing enough to
include the perspectives of victims
families she particularly focused on one
popular recent example Netflix's Dharma
monster the Jeffrey Dahmer story has
generated a lot of controversy with
ethical concerns over its depiction of
events details from the show set and the
showrunners reportedly not Consulting
the families of dharma's victims yes the
series also smashed a Netflix record by
becoming the streamer's biggest debut
ever dramatizations of real-life crimes
really have to walk a fine line while
entirely fictional crime series like
Ozark and good girls can get away with
some comic relief and outlandish
storylines True Crime is a
responsibility to depict events at least
fairly close to how they really happened
according to Kim Goldman monster did not
hit that Target she is the sister of Ron
Goldman the man who was killed alongside
Nicole Brown Simpson in 1994. O.J
Simpson was tried in a quick for both
murders Kim is now a writer who also
works with non-profit organizations on a
variety of cases as the sister of a
high-profile murder victim she did not
mince words in her criticism of monster
in an interview with Entertainment
Weekly Goldman said some article said
Netflix is not required to notify the
families and it bugged me how shitty is
that that it doesn't even dawn on you
from just a human space that you would
give someone a courtesy call Goldman
added that when she and her family heard
about the effects series The People vs
O.J Simpson American Crime Story they
reached out to ask what they could learn
we asked if we could see an advanced
copy we were told no I said well that's
unfortunate it kind of works against you
if you were to at least share it with me
then I would be able to say hey they
shared it with me and this is what I
feel about it missed opportunity the
people vs O.J Simpson and monster both
are the same executive producer Ryan
Murphy you know there's so many places
that they took creative Liberties and a
part of me is thinking you know why do
we need the show we had it on television
gavel to gavel for 10 months Goldman has
raised the possibility of a law
requiring filmmakers to consult with
families she speculated as to the
reasons why creative teams would not
contact families saying I would imagine
it's because of the pushback that a
production company or a network would
receive if a family got wind of a
project and wanted some kind of
involvement Goldman's issue with True
Crime shows and films like Consulting
families isn't just about a lack of
courtesy viewers have the expectation
that what they're viewing is a
fictionalized but still largely accurate
account of events but a well-rounded
account of what happened would be
difficult to portray without consulting
the families of victims Goldman compared
the idea of a true crime show that
doesn't consult those families to an
unauthorized biography written without
the subject's permission or knowledge
she said when or if I choose to read
that book now I know the lens with which
to view it I feel like that could be
applied to these types of shows and then
people can decide whether to watch it
I'm not trying to stop people from
watching but just maybe to have a
different sensitivity as you can soon
the show that it wasn't that the
pleasure of the victim's family Goldman
also shared that she asked Jeffrey tubin
the author of the book that monster was
based on about why family members of
dharma's victims were not consulted she
recalled he said well it wasn't victim
focused and I'm like well that's the
problem Goldman added I think it's
changed a little bit over the last
couple of years but most of the shows
are from the criminal's perspective from
the law enforcement perspective from the
legal perspective very seldom do you
often see it from a victim's perspective
it paints a picture that victims and
survivors are in the background you know
in a fetal position on the floor She
said the experience of the victims is
just as important as those of the
criminals and the police Goldman said
it's irresponsible to not in some way
include the families so that you can
understand what they're experiencing and
to give a little bit more power back to
them
foreign